il ya un an je me posais un capteur sur
le torse un capteur qui vibrait à chaque
fois que je m'orientais vers le nord et
qui faisait de moi un cyborg j'ai pu le
tester lors de différents voyages et gel
est notamment montré un ami népalais qui
a pu me poser plusieurs questions je
devais ensuite le tester plus longuement
pour voir les premiers effets ces deux
épisodes sont disponibles en
descriptions
de plus je mets 50 euros que d'ici un an
son nouveau sens super yachts il trop
cyborg lol sera parti à la poubelle
bref ridicule pour le coup mais avant il
va évidemment nous lâcher sa réflexion
sur le transhumanisme exactement lieu
les potes c'est le dernier épisode
autour de cette série
voilà ça c'est absolument pas passées
comme prévu voilà deux du plein
d'aspects différents
déjà ce qui s'est passé c'est qu'il
après la vidéo quand je suis revenu à
katmandou donc ça c'était à peu près
l'année dernière capteur s'est cassé du
coup j'ai contacté la boîte pour
expliquer ce qui s'est passé je
redemande à un nouveau et non gentiment
envoyé
sauf qu'en fait j'ai pas pu le mettre
parce que
mon piercing à comment ça s'est infectée
et en fait ça s'est infectée s'est
infectée et cetera donc moi je luttais
un coup de deux produits désinfectants
par ci par là etc c'est un machin en
discutant avec mon père soeur pour pour
trouver une solution
et oui d'un moment après plusieurs mois
je n'ai pas envie on laisse tomber quoi
on arrête
et donc j'ai j'ai tout retirer alors je
suis même pas sûr qu'il ya des
cicatrices qui soit visible à la caméra
a évidemment quand ça arrive et c'est un
genre
au début ça m'a fait rire vaty surtout
je trouve ça marrant bien tout ce qui
s'est passé genre le fait que
je deviens un cyborg et ou expérience de
ouf et en fait non pas du tout georges
et s'est hissée je sais je sais je sais
et ça marche pas à jeun donc donc non
c'est assez drôle et maintenant en fait
c est tellement longtemps
ce que c'est un peu comme si j'étais
passé à autre chose dans ma tête donc je
suis
je suis même plus blasés ou même plus
triste ex tâche est plus en mode
ok mon bac qu'est-ce qu'on peut tirer au
maximum de ce qui s'est passé là et si
je peux partager avec les gens qui peut
être intéressant donc j'ai pris quelques
questions et quelques commentaires qui
revenait extrêmement souvent et on va en
parler parce que voilà il ya plein de
choses à se dire alors déjà il ya plein
de commentaires sur le fait que mec il
ya la boussole qui existe tu as une
application boussole sur son téléphone
le soleil les étoiles machin enfin bref
et là je me dis et il ya là quelques uns
quelques-uns qui l'ont souligné dans les
commentaires je me dis beaucoup de gens
n'ont pas compris
en fait on pas compris le but de la
démarche etc et non peut-être même pas
compris en fait ce que c'est un sens
quelque part en fait il ya une
différence qui est fondamental avec tout
ça que ce soit la boussole ou que ce
soit regarder le soleil ou voilà ce
genre de choses et le capteur la
différence fondamentale c'est que les
choses dont j'ai parlé avant c'est des
outils c'est à dire que j'y pense j'en
ai besoin je vais chercher l'information
c'est moi qui fait la démarche d'aller
chercher l'information les sens c'est
pas des outils
l'information vient à toi que tu le
veuilles ou non quant à fait une
transaction qui n'enlève pas tes
oreilles tu as tes oreilles et jordi des
fois il ya des sons qui sont pas
agréables mais tu as quand même genre
c'est de l'information qui est constante
tu vois là vu pareille le toucher pareil
genton d'amin ne va pas arrêter de
sentir à ce que tu veux que s'arrête de
sentir genre tu te couches aime quand tu
vas dormir tu sens le poids du drap sur
toi et c'est par mach 1 alors que t'en
as pas besoin à ce moment là tu es ce
que je veux dire ça c'est une différence
fondamentale en fait si je voulais avoir
une boussole de l'otan ce moment je
prends rien ne bouge tout le temps sur
m'enfin c'est pas le spa ça le principe
c'est pas ça le
principe de base du truc le principe de
base du truc c'est que ce n'est pas un
outil c'est que je ne je n'ai pas à
choisir de choper cette information
c'est une différence fondamentale ce que
c'est censé faire c'est qu'en fait au
bout d'un moment donc tu as tout le
temps au début consciemment puis
inconsciemment une des repères nord sud
est ouest dans la tête et en fait ce qui
se passe c'est que par exemple j'ai pas
tu vas tu vas une soirée tu vas chez des
potes noël par exemple on se souvient
tous de son noël on se souvient des
odeurs on se souvient de des gens se
souvient des sons se souvient de plein
de choses qui étaient sensorielle et ben
c'est comme si en plus de ça toi tu te
souviens de la localisation de ton
espace par rapport aux champs
magnétiques de la terre c'est à dire que
voilà tu te souviens que le nord ce
départ l' homo c'est que c'est juste une
informations sensorielles de + 1
question à quoi ça sert s'est passé je
suis pas sûr que ce soit le but que ça
serve à quelque chose
peut-être que si je l'avais eue et que
je l'avais travailler j'aurais pu le
dire bah [ __ ] en fait ça a servi à ça
je m'attendais pas du tout à ce que ça
serve à ça mais en fait ça m'a
totalement ouvert ce champ là et genre
c'est hyper intéressant
voilà où peut-être que je suis devenu
une brute en feng shui
j'en sais rien tu vois je sais pas c'est
pas ça en fait le le but du truc en ça
on va y revenir on va y revient un peu
plus tard sur l'utilité et la perception
de certains d'entre vous par rapport à
ça mais je sais que par exemple moi
quand j'en parlais avec donc les gars
qui ont fondé le truc ce qui le portait
genre plusieurs semaines ex plusieurs
mois de suite
il avait ce qu'ils ont commencé à
appeler entre la vision et les coop
terre il avait une sorte de vision
radars qui s'est pas une vraie vision
s'appuie sur un truc qui sentait un
radar où il savait où était les choses
ce qui est logique tant que j'en sais je
sors de chez moi et puis je sais pas moi
je vais chez un pote et ben en fait
inconsciemment je sais chez moi c'est
derrière quel mur parce que je veux dire
parce que je sais exactement où est chez
moi tu vois quelle direction il faut que
je prenne pour arriver à chez moi
précisément et donc ça ça te donne une
sorte de vision un peu hélicoptère qui
est un autre gars avec qui j'en parlais
qui lui disait que en gros l'idée
apparaît quand je les ai vus et en fait
il vient de londres
en fait expliqué cachent pas qu'ils se
tournaient vers londres l'udc avait son
fils là bas ils ressentent et genre une
petite émotion agréable improbable quoi
improbable et donc nous ne nous arrive
pas en tant qu'humain parce qu'on n'a
pas ce sens lights est un machin mais il
est évident que si tu développes entre
guillemets des aptitudes bien que ce
soit via une technologie
il est évident que ça ça change la
perception de plein de choses avec ça un
impact sur toi c'est sûr y'a pas de
débat là dessus cette pose pas problème
pour passer les frontières dans les
aéroports etc
non non tu peux l'enlever et puis ça
presque comme un piercing le piercing se
pose pas problème pour passer aéroports
saluer ce que ton quatre heures a déjà
déconner il s'arrête pas de livrer par
exemple je pense notamment au moment où
tu prends l'avion ou lorsque tu te
retrouve entourée de beaucoup de champs
magnétiques
ah ouais ouais grave en fait quand tu
prends le métro par exemple ou métro ils
pètent un câble quoi il devient où il ça
vibre de tous les côtés ça vu passard
vibre ils vont ça vibre plus du tout
enfin c'est assez marrant et c'était
marrant comme le métro de paris par
exemple se comporter de manière très
différente métro de new york en termes
de deux champs magnétiques et ces
machins je veux savoir s'il ya d'autres
objets du même style et pourquoi avoir
voulu essayer avec ce capteur et qu'elle
en est l'annoncé futur va plein de trucs
différentes ça va de la puce rfid que tu
vas mettre sous les doigts un truc que
tu mets sous les doigts qui permet de
sentir un peu le champ magnétique des
choses ou à une meuf moon qui a mis une
sorte de
samy une sorte de capteurs qui fait que
ressent quand il ya des séismes sur
terre donc là plein de trucs tu as plein
de gens qui essaient des choses dans
leur coin et c'est un machin
cet objet las une dernière fois où genre
il ya une tentative de démocratisation
du truc sur quelque chose qui est assez
poussé quand même super désagréable à
voir un truc qui vibre dès que tu bouges
alors en fait non c'est l'inversé
ce genre super agréable d'ailleurs
c'était marrant parce que quand je le
portais souvent j'étais là quand j'avais
besoin d'attendre un truc je me mettais
face au nord je faisais comme ça déjà
passé un peu de vent tu vois devant le
nord devrait rester c'était agréable
quoi des coûts s'est développé une sorte
de toc c'est une question bête mais
l'implant et waterproof
c'est pas une question bête et l'implant
est waterproof question est-ce que
consciemment tu dois réfléchir à caen ça
vibre pour savoir où est le nord où est
ce qu'après un certain temps c'est
automatique et j'ai appris à y réfléchir
et tu peux parfaitement tout représenter
ton orientation spatio temporelle alors
je suis arrivé au stade où en gros
j'avais une intuition d'intuition de
l'espace qui souvent se confirmait quand
je passais en mode conscient et j'essaie
de réfléchir à un mode retrouver le truc
mais le stade l'intuition je commence à
la voir sur hier j'ai discuté avec un
pote et une fait c'est quoi ce que tu as
tiré cette expérience mecs qui en fait
je me suis rendu compte que ce que j'ai
tiré c'était avant tout le manteau une
vraie expérience sociale en fait et ce
qui m'a le plus marqué là dedans c'est à
quel point ça à gênés des gens à quel
point ça les a mis mal à l'aise à quel
point ça les a presque fait chier quoi
tu vois j'ai l'impression que quand il
ya des gens que je dérangeais et c'était
marrant parce qu'en temps normal tu vois
sur n'importe quelle expérience que ce
soit les gens sont là à temps et on va
voir assez ouais pourquoi il fait ça
mais ça ne sert à rien asie mais je
comprends pas l'utilité d'un truc comme
ça
et pourquoi pas pris une boussole la fin
tu vois il y avait un vrai vrai
agacement cours des gens que ça c'est
hyper intéressant je m'attendais pas du
tout du tout à ça et en fait ça m'a fait
penser un livre un livre de marketing
qui est vraiment bien si jamais vous
entreprenez dans la nouvelle technologie
je vous conseille crépel crossing des
casques et donc dans crossing des casses
mme à un moment il parle de ce diagramme
c'est la courbe d'adoption des nouvelles
technologies donc si on a les
innovateurs et si on allait heures les
adopteurs si ici on a la peur les
majorités dans les pragmatiques ici on
halal est mature et il est conservateur
et si on a ceux qui sont un peu à la
traîne c'est les scellés sceptiques donc
par exemple quand le smartphone est
sorti tu as une infime partie la
population qui était genre vraiment à
fond pendant que d'autres gens disaient
genre au bon je vois pas trop l'intérêt
j'ai déjà mon téléphone j'ai déjà mon
ordinateur pourquoi je rien voilà
pourquoi j'aurai un smartphone ensuite
il ya un peu plus de gens qui rejoint le
truc
et là il ya un truc qui est hyper
important qui s'appelle de casse mme le
fossé entre guillemets et beaucoup de
nouvelles technologies se plante ici
beaucoup de nouvelles technologies ne
passe pas dans le mainstream
aujourd'hui par exemple tout ce qu'est
match tout ce qui est montre connectés
etc
c'est pas mainstream s'est toujours pas
remis ni stream et ça le sera peut-être
jamais et en fait les gens qui sont là
ils sont vu les gens qui sont ici comme
des fous quoi comme des mecs
pourquoi le mec achète ça sauf qu'en
fait on a besoin des gens qui sont là si
on veut qu'un jour déjà le produit
évolue le produit sa meilleure extra on
a besoin de gens qui entre guillemets
investissent dedans qui teste des choses
qui se plante aussi bref qui voilà qui
expérimentent quoi pour que ces
produits-là s'améliore et pour
qu'ensuite potentiellement ce
s'affranchissent le casque ou pas je
vous donne un exemple peut-être ça le
plus clair ce téléphone c'est le
motorola 8000x je me d'autres photos ici
il est sorti il coûtait 3995 dollar en
1983 c'est l'équivalent de dix mille
dollars aujourd'hui pour un cours aux
trucs comme as évidemment quand c'est
sorti tu as plein de gens qui étaient là
jamais sauf qu'en fait heureusement
qu'ils étaient là les mecs qui ont
acheté ça parce que ça montrer aux gens
qu'ils produisent ce genre d'objet que
ça peut intéresser les gens et en fait
c'est grâce à ça grâce à cette première
personne que on a l'espoir de faire des
compagnies qui est bref donc c'est
marrant parce que du coup ça a donné
autant d'informations sur plusieurs gens
qui me suivent que sur moi georges lot
si la wii en fait je pensais pas que
j'étais aussi seuls quelque part dans ce
délire alors évidemment je suis pas le
seul genre même dans les commentaires il
ya plein de gens qui comprenait le
délire et ces machins j'ai reçu plein de
messages privés j'ai reçu des messages
aussi de gens qui développent des trucs
qu'il tente des choses et c'est donc
c'est super cool genre ça m'a permis de
me rapprocher de ces gens là aussi mais
ouais je me suis rendu compte que ok en
fait on est vraiment
petite niche quoi peut-être que jamais
se casse cette frontière ne sera franchi
peut-être que jamais ce sera mystream
peut-être que n'aura peut-être jamais
une partie de la population qui est
cyborg je pense pas je pense même que
quelque part on l'est déjà quoi d'une
certaine façon après voilà c'est par
exemple pas les pacemakers ou même les
lunettes moi quand je parle des lunettes
avec des gens les gens me disent ouais
mais ça c'est pour t'amener au niveau
normal pas pour le dépasser je vais mais
[ __ ] mais qui a décidé que c'est le
niveau normal quoi c'est pas parce qu'il
y avait un gars qui avait dix sur dix
ans déjà on appelait ça 10 sur 10 mais
je veux dire sera pu être une eau de
notation et genre on aurait pu dire que
ce mec là c'est pas la norme il voit
mieux que normal
peut-être que la norme ce témoin j'en
sais rien peut-être que demain on aura
tous 15 sur 10 tu as peut-être que
demain on aura tous 20 sur nice et que
le mec avait 10 sur 10
bah c'est naze je trouve que tout ça
c'est très c'est très subjectif quoi
c'est très arbitraire et le tout ce qui
est cyborg tout ce qui est
transhumanisme ça remet en question sa
et du coup ça gêne enfin bref voilà
c'était je sais pas si je serai
aborderait le sujet ici sur ma chaîne
etc ou de quelle façon c'était super
intéressant à faire c'est un sujet qui
continue à m'intéresser peut-être que je
vais retenter le truc d'une autre
manière c'est à dire que par exemple au
lieu d'utiliser un piercing et ses
acquis un truc assez lourd d'une
certaine manière
peut-être que je sais pas on va trouver
un autre système
peut-être que j'ai ya quelqu'un qui
regarde cette vidéo qui est en train de
développer quelque chose qui permet de
continuer l'expérience mais avec
beaucoup moins de deux coups d'une
certaine manière
alors je sais que le l'objet non c'était
le 900 g qu'il est plus disponible
il ya des gens qui paraît d'obsolescence
programmée et ses genres en mode combien
de ckoi la durée de vie du truc je sais
pas trop je sais qu'on a un groupe
facebook avec tous les gens qui en ont
un à certains sur le groupe qui disent
voilà
bien il marche plus depuis quelques mois
et c'est donc pas j'en sais rien j'ai
pas assez de données pour vous donner
une réponse là dessus mais je crois que
cette sincèrement sincèrement je le
pense je crois que c'est pas ça qui
compte
ce qui compte c'est pas c'est pas
vraiment l'aube ce que fait l'objet et
combien de temps et durer et est-ce que
ça laisse des cicatrices quoi enfin
c'est pas et je pense que si on posait
la question mais qui avaient acheté des
motorola 8000x il dirait aussi ouais
enfin oui la batterie dure 20 minutes
mais c'est pas ça qui compte
tu vois je me souviens mon tout premier
lecteur mp3 mon père m'avait acheté un
lecteur mp3 j'étais trop content si je
pouvais mettre onze chansons dedans
c'était pas le nom de chansons qui
comptait quoi évidemment les gens qu'une
vidéo ça va mettre en chanson et ouais
mais c'est un lecteur mp3 moi c'est ça
qui me fait vibrer je contentait de
nouvelles choses découvrir jus ce qu'on
est capable de faire
jusqu'où on peut aller avec tout ce que
ça comporte comme risques aussi et tout
ce que ça comporte comme danger mais
c'est ça c'est être à l'avant-garde de
l'humanité moi c'est ça qui me fait
vibrer en fait je m'en branle en fait de
savoir si oulmers pas ça qui compte
voilà j'espère que
j'espère que c'est plus clair pour
beaucoup de gens qui suivent et qui
comprenait pas forcément ça donc ça va
pas marcher
je pense que c'est aussi quelque part ça
montre qu' on n'est pas prêt on n'est
pas prêt à ce genre de truc en tout cas
via cette technologie là pour qu'on
trouve le meilleur moyen rencontre de
meilleures solutions faut qu'on éduque
les gens aussi être moins apporté - le
jugement être avoir plus de
bienveillance pour ça que je vous ai
montré aussi ce passage avec avec alice
et que c'est marrant le nombre d'entre
vous qui qui portent des intentions à
alice et qui projette eux leurs pensées
sur ali osant ouais je suis sûr qu'elle
y pense ça non non ça c'est ta vision
ethnocentrée en fait que tu aurais
percute sur ali mais genre c'est faux tu
vois ouais voilà c'est pour ça je
voulais aussi montrer ce passage là
c'est à quel point lors il est possible
d'avoir une bienveillance une innocence
par rapport à ça a juste manqué et
pourquoi hockey soit choisi et c'était
intéressant voir où et à quel point
c'est ça pouvait agacer certains d'entre
eux j'espère que ça vous a plu
j'espère que ça vous a interrogé c'est
super important pour moi que vous vous
posez des questions que je provoque ça
que ce soit via des vidéos de philo pur
comme j'ai eu l'habitude de faire ou que
ce soit aussi par des expériences très
fortes comme cyborg vous embrasse très
fort je vous souhaite une très bonne
année 2010 9
tous mes meilleurs voeux santé amour et
réussite dans vos projets j'embrasse
fort
merci de me suivre et à bientôt
[Musique]
e